what is the logic behind Terror attacks
such as the one which occurred in the
early hours of New Year's Day when a
Muslim man plowed his truck into people
in New Orleans killing 15 wounding
dozens the same thing actually happened
a few days earlier on December 20th talb
Abdul msen a Muslim man from Saudi
Arabia with a long history of pretending
to be a Critic of Islam and a convert to
Christianity Etc plowed his vehicle
through a crowded Christmas Market in
Germany killing five and injuring about
200 people both of these attacks the
median officials were and are at a loss
establishing motive other than telling
us the usual that the men were suffering
from mental psychiatric disorders that
they had grievances that they had
personal problems in their lives and so
on and so forth yet the motive which as
we shall see does seem erratic and
counterintuitive was spelled out exactly
one year ago today and as such is worth
revisiting on January 3rd 2024 the
Islamic State Isis issued a state making
seemingly strange and bizarre
assertions for starters the terror group
took responsibility for bombing Israel's
Arch Enemy Iran and killing about 100
people in Kerman it also told Muslims
that although Israel and Jews are indeed
the chief and Arch enemies of Islam and
although Muslims were then irate at what
was happening in Palestine now was not
the time to fight Israel as to what
Muslims should do Isis urged them to
randomly kill people in the west from
here it is a of course easy to see why
some accuse the terror group of being
created by the CIA mosad Etc and yet and
here's the interesting part everything
Isis said was indeed connected to
Islamic teaching and law first they
attacked Iran because as a Shia Nation
not only is it not Muslim and therefore
an Infidel enemy like the rest but it's
something of a wolf and sheep's clothing
to the average Sunni Muslim it seems
Islamic enough and it seemingly
Champions Islamic causes such as the
Palestinians V Israel Etc in reality
Isis argues that Iran is no less of an
enemy than so-called Jews or Crusaders
in the statement that they have the same
nefarious plots etc etc second in its
statement Isis counseled Muslims not to
fight Israel because the primary
beneficiary would be the Palestinian
Authority the
PA which because it does not enforce
Sharia is no less an Infidel than Israel
and what's the point of toppling one
Infidel power Israel only to replace it
by another let me read you a quote from
the
statement the battle with the Jews is a
religious one and not a nationalist or
populist one is it is not a battle for
land soil or borders a Muslim fights the
Jews because they have committed KF
disbelief against Allah Almighty the
purpose of battle is to impose toed for
Allah and upholding his word this
purpose has been absent from the latest
battle in
Gaza Isis even went on to mock the
concept of Palestinian Liberation they
wrote this interpretation of Liberation
itself requires Liberation liberating a
land does not mean to free it from one
secular government in favor of a
democratic one and it does not mean
releasing it from a Jewish Constitution
only to be governed by a Palestinian
constitution for the laws that govern
Palestine and the Jewish stat lit are
one they are man-made and all such
governments are alike to Almighty Allah
they're bad a land not ruled by Islam
Sharia is not liberated even if all the
Jews and Invaders leave it in fact it is
still a captive of kuf laws KF meaning
non-muslim Infidel etc etc all
right finally returning to recent events
plowing Vehicles into and killing people
in the west this too of course was
isis's idea and its counsel to its
followers as actually reflected in the
very title of the statement that it
issued the title was kill them wherever
you find them and this is a paraphrase
of Quran
95 which in Islamic Juris Prudence is
known as the verse of the sword and in
that scripture Allah calls on the
Believers the Muslims to kill the mush
wherever you find them capture them
besiege them lie and wait for them in
every way and kill them mushin is Arabic
for essentially the polytheists pagans
idolators which is an umbrella term for
essentially all non-muslims including
Christians because of the Trinity
they're seen as polytheists in this
sense at any rate in keeping with that
Mandate of Quran 995 Isis urged Muslims
to let me read you the
quote in the statement it urged Muslims
to chase your praise whether Jewish
Christian or their allies on the streets
and roads of America Europe and the
world break into their homes kill them
steal their Peace of Mind by any means
you can lay hands on detonate explosives
burn them With Grenades and fiery agents
shoot them with bullets cut their
throats with sharp knives and run them
over with vehicles come at them from
every door kill them by the worst of
means turn their Gatherings and
celebrations such as New Year's Day into
bloody massacres do not distinguish
between a civilian uh cfer Infidel and a
military one for they are all kufar
infidels and the ruling against them is
one and the same meaning they all should
be killed according to Quran 95 so such
is the seeming capric and nihilism of
Islamic terrorism it knows no bounds and
can strike at any time in any place
without at least in the eyes of
so-called infidels Rhyme or Reason as
evidenced by all the random Terror
attacks to plague Western
cities uh in recent years if you've been
paying attention and a great many of
these have consisted specifically of
Muslims plowing their vehicles into
non-muslims the most notorious of which
probably occurred in nce in France in
2016 when a Muslim man drove a big rig
truck over people celebrating bastile
day killing 87 of them and wounding
437 so there it is some context as to
what propelled the New Orleans Massacre
with which New Year opened with